>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> The Law Library of Congress
has an account of many trials
in its rare book collection.
This is an account of the
trial of Richard Lawrence
for his attempt on the life
of President Andrew Jackson.
This item was printed by
William Mitchell, who operated
out of 265 Bowery
in New York City.
Mitchell printed a variety of
titles in the 1830s and took
on a partner in 1837
named Turner.
Other Mitchells continued to
operate out of the same address
into the late 19th Century.
On January 30, 1835, an
unemployed painter by the name
of Richard Lawrence made the
first attempt on the life
of a sitting U.S. President,
President Andrew Jackson
President Jackson had traveled
to the Capitol Building
to attend a Congressional
funeral in the House Wing.
As the President
exited the funeral,
he approached the east
portico of the Capitol.
Lawrence drew a pistol
from his pocket and fired,
but only the cap fired.
Even though he was 67
and in poor health,
the President charged
Lawrence with a cane.
Before the President
could reach him,
Lawrence produced a second
pistol and pulled the trigger.
This pistol also misfired,
allowing the President
to reach Lawrence, who
ducked to avoid being struck
by the President's cane, which
is what you see depicted here.
The President reportedly
yelled, "Let me alone!
Let me alone!
I know where this came from."
Lawrence was then
subdued by onlookers
and the President was taken by
carriage to the White House.
The political environment of
the time was highly charged due
to the President's veto of the
bill to reauthorize the charter
of the Second Bank
of the United States.
Some believed Lawrence was the
instrument of a Whig conspiracy,
including the President himself.
Despite these early claims,
scholars now believe
Lawrence acted alone
and of his own accord.
Lawrence claimed that the
President had killed his father,
a claim that was quickly
revealed to be false.
Lawrence also said he
was King Richard the III,
and the President's
opposition to the Second Bank
of the United States had
denied him the ability
to receive a dispensation
owed to him by Congress
To bolster his claim
he was a monarch,
Lawrence dressed the
part of royalty at trial,
sporting a shooting
jacket and cravat
that you see depicted here.
He also expressed some
indignation at the fact
that he was being
judged by commoners.
After the jury was instructed,
Lawrence said, "It is for me,
gentlemen, to pass upon
you, and not you upon me."
The jury found Lawrence not
guilty by reason of insanity
and he was confined to an
asylum for the remainder
of his life before
passing away in 1861.
>> This has been a
presentation of the Library
of Congress, visit
us at LOC.gov.